[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by May Calla Maui
AKA Dina in Romney season three which
appears Friday on Hulu how you doing
today May
good how are you I'm doing great I'm
just so excited to talk to you I love
this show I love your performance in it
and I actually want to jump back to
season one for a second in episode six
which is one of the Dina centered
episodes I love this moment I can relate
to it a lot where there's a moment she's
talking to her father and it's a
traumatic moment to me where he's saying
how the devil's watching her if she has
sex before marriage I'm wondering at
this moment do you think Dina
already know this doesn't sound right or
she like completely absorbing All This
and like being influenced by it or is
there already kind of like a smarter
rebellious thing in her
well she was given that advice when she
was young right so I think at that age
you're you know you just you're a sponge
and you trust your parents more than
anyone and so it's definitely sunk in
um but as as she's grown up it's
something that she wants to explore and
and then you you know you have the urges
and then you're told it's wrong and
that's where most people are caught for
some time or a lot of people
yeah and I like that it's something that
they delve into later on and or when
she's older now and I also love when
they sent her in on Dina in episode five
of season two was my favorite episode of
the show so far focusing on the hair
loss too
um can we though expect another Dina
focused episode this season and would be
maybe even as heavy as season two kind
of was with her this season feels
slightly more Ensemble and that we're
we're a bit more integrated with each
other
um we're all going through our own
Journeys I don't it's not specifically a
dina-centric episode but there are uh I
want to say two episodes where there is
more of Dina and what she's going
through
um
I feel like Dina is just a deep
character there's so much going on
underneath and she's still trying to
figure out what that is it's not like
she's aware and she's hiding all of it
she's she's in a moment where she's
deeply trying to excavate what's going
on and like something's not okay
yeah that's interesting I'm excited to
see that in season three and see her do
more of that and what I also like seeing
Dana do is to me she's the voice of
reason in the show and calls out a lot
of double standards
you though as may do you agree with her
all the time like when you're reading
those parts or is there any times you
kind of haven't agreed with her in those
situations
I I don't always agree with Dina it
feels like she her identity has been
based on her being contrarian and I'm
not like that at all interesting she
always has an opinion and it's where she
I don't want to say she's validating off
of it but there is something to that and
and I think this season
that comes into question a little with
some of our choices and and her seeing
them a bit more clearly and starting to
really question
um why she's
taken the path she's taken
interesting and it's interesting to hear
you sometimes not agree that I like that
and it shows how good you perform it I
guess I gotta take illusion of the
actors out of my head for a second but
um we also see too that Dina is a law
student what about law do you think
attracts Dina why long laws like Dina's
religion she's she likes to to be in
control and grasp what has reason and
logic and can be explained and you're
not going to see her put her faith in
something as easily as that
um and I think as someone who needs that
control it is comforting the the like
she's also
deeply rooted in in wanting to help and
and social justice
but I as I've you know
been involved with this character for a
while I start to question how much of
that is really her and how much of it is
it's her ego and her just trying to like
satisfy something
um and prove she's better than someone
else you know it feels like there is a
lot of that going on
yeah and I like just the answers you're
giving about her because it just shows
how well written the character is and
how complicated the character is so I
really like that answer and
last season two we see you got to work
with the great mahershal Ali what was
that like and is there anything you
learned from that experience working
with him
I didn't have many scenes with
mahershala but I I loved it and what
I'll say is
um I I I I learned watching him on set
not necessarily in in performance
because I'm you know that's weird if I'm
like watching him while we're in a
second but he's he's just very
um kind and humble and was introducing
himself to everyone and and speaking to
everyone
um and he just has a great energy to him
he's very helpful I always tell the
story where I had to deliver a line to
him
his character and he he couldn't be
there because the camera had to be there
and he somehow heard he was in another
knee ran over and he's like it's okay
I'll find her eye line and I was like I
can't see you and he's like I'll just
stand here and I just thought it's
really generous and it taught me that I
never want to
um lose sight of that the more I work
it's awesome person yeah yeah that's
great it's great to hear he's a team
player like that too so also just
shifting gears a bit I love that you
share on your Instagram the intense
training you did for Moon night no come
is it hard to come down from that
intensive physical role to then like
going back into Romney and playing Dino
which is you know not that as demanding
physically is that kind of crazy
sometimes sometimes I'm like Rami and I
will be talking and I won't be or I'll
have questions about a moment or a
pardon and I'll laugh I'll be like I'm
just so intense like if I'm not or
flying off of a building suddenly it
feels like it's not enough you know yeah
hell yeah I could totally see that
um and speaking of Moon Knight 2 how
does it feel to be the first Egyptian
superhero in the MCU but also the great
impact it's having on people are you
pinching yourself constantly thinking
about it
it's really it's really cool and I in a
way I don't know what else I can do with
it like I haven't even I hardly touched
my social media because I'm like I
I don't know like for me I'm grateful
this is like a dream you know and then I
I think I I remember based on the
reactions I get from fans like the
photos they sent me or the comments that
they they write I'm just like wow this
really impacted people it's a little
instiller when you're in it because
you're just around the people you film
with right I'm not like talking to
people all the time I don't get
recognized I don't I just don't I forget
sometimes that I did this and then
someone will show me a Funko Pop and
I'll be like oh that's really cool
okay that's great you mentioned that
because I was just gonna ask about the
Funko Pops I think it's awesome too that
you don't just have one Funko Pop you
have two because you have Layla and
Scarlet Scarab that's huge so like do
you nerd out to something like that do
you have an inner nerd in you
honestly no like I read Archie growing
up I didn't read a lot of comics
I think it's exciting
um I'm more excited by like how people
are excited by it for me I'm just like
okay I want more Layla uh what story are
we gonna tell what's she gonna do I'm
like craving
more for the female Arab you know that's
new a lot of times people are like
you're the first or hey this thing is
here and I'm like okay yeah it's about
time now let's go like what else do we
want to tell right and so maybe like I
need to just be present in the moment a
bit more
um but I'm just like excited
I'm excited and I want to keep sharing
yeah I love that answer and yeah let's
just get more of it let's just not stop
that's exciting and I I can't wait to
see more of Layla so also before I let
you go what do you want people to take
away the most from season three of
Romney or even just Dina's story in a
sense
um
I want people to have fun it felt like
season two got a bit more serious in
ways and I think that season comes back
to its comedic three comes back to its
comedic Edge
um
I want people to remember this is just a
family like we can call it Muslim Arab
all of these labels and of course these
are parts of their identity that's
important to consider but they're also
just a family that's struggling and we
all struggle um and also not struggling
but but we're all just trying to live
and I think a lot of these
um bumps that they're hitting are
Universal and just to focus more on how
we're alike and thus how we're different
I think that's cool
yeah I love that and I'm excited for
people to see this everyone watch me be
brilliant and Romney season three it's
premiering Friday on Hulu May thank you
so much for joining me today and I hope
to talk to you in the future